i don't even realize i'm doing anything
with me
she likes me
and then so it like casey's obviously
not receiving that as like oh she's
flirting he's just like i don't like
being tickled stop tickling me right you
want to know who likes you even as a
person not even necessarily flirting
with you but yes who actually likes you
say something and watch who doesn't
react yeah
but it just feels so silly to flirt but
then we i don't intentionally do it but
that's cute it works
isn't just supposed to be like i'm
trying to get you in my bed flirting is
showing interest it's whatever makes you
feel good it's it's life
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to big mood
who do we have with that today did you
make that out because i totally just
yeah what is it
who do we have today but my tongue got
all twisted my cheek is all cut up in
the inside it's kind of hard to speak
today but yeah who do we have hi it's me
it's your girl gina what's up yeah
hi it's nikki blades it's nikki blaze we
have over here
guest host because
as you can see oh and by the way i'm
tiffany but as you can see
nikki uh limo yes and jess aren't here
so it's just the three of us i'm the
other nicki yeah yeah we call her blades
yes i feel like i've been here enough
times that you all know who i am yeah
yeah
you're our favorite one of our many
favorites because we have a lot of
favorites yeah
you're just saying that so that they
don't get upset but i know the truth
so and you guys know the truth
but no offense to the others the other
nikki
the other the other favorite the other
favorite
all right so today we're gonna be
talking about uh we're gonna go through
this list of people sharing obvious
signs of flirting that sometimes a lot
of people tend to miss
and so i thought it would be kind of fun
to just talk about different flirting
techniques i
have never really
ever
truly intentionally tried to flirt like
oh really
if i do flirt i think it comes out by
accident like okay i'm not purposely
doing it also if i like someone i get
really nervous yeah and i feel like i
can't purposely flirt yeah there have
been some people were like surprisingly
my friends like what like i when i meet
someone i get i get nervous
which is really weird for me because i
don't get nervous yeah but sometimes
it's just like he is so fine
yeah you're just like
yeah
i don't know i end up like getting
extra shy
because that's like already i think
with new people i end up being kind of
shyish
but then yeah like if it's someone that
makes me nervous i'm just like i'm gonna
be super quiet that's how i know i
actually like you if you make me nervous
because i
know how to flirt yeah
i know i'm really interested to hear how
you feel right i don't think this will
help people i am a big player i am a big
i am a big person
hopefully this will help people kind of
identify when someone's flirting with
you because i've read so many yeah posts
about people who don't realize that
someone was flirting with them yeah and
they post about it and people are like
are you dumb like it's so obvious
they're so oblivious to it yeah yeah
some of it's very subtle some of it's
more like you know it's straightforward
the art of flirting changes depending on
who you are talking to and you should
keep that in mind yes talking like a
real pro you should be very aware of who
you are flirting with and that's why
some signs are not as obvious to certain
people because that's not what they
would consider flirting and so when
you're trying to flirt with someone one
of the best ways to do that is to also
know who you're flirting with so you got
to test things out but yes that's why
sometimes it's not so obvious because
you'll be like
what's wrong with your eye
why are you blinking so much and
ladies and gentlemen if you think just
batting your eyelashes at somebody is
flirting in 2022 you we you're about to
go to school today
so grab your pens they're your papers
your uh your phones
there's like physical flirting there's
verbal flow there's like
small like little like physical there's
energetic yeah i can send my energy to
you oh let me tell you
i got a few tricks she got a few tricks
let's do this i'm eager to learn even
though i'll never use this information
no you can't use it yeah
version of flirting with casey is so
pathetic no no no no your dick
hey i told i told a friend
i was i was talking to this guy and the
scenario to where i was like oh my god
we were flirting with each other was so
cute we're talking about pokemon and
[ __ ] my friend was like you're [ __ ]
dork did you just get excited
i was like yeah he called me his little
pokemon and she's like
she's like what is wrong with you i was
like that ain't cute that's hella cute
yes i will be your pokemon if i can take
a peek at you
you got to know who you're talking to
yeah because that should turn me on
yeah no i'm saying it's pathetic because
this doesn't
it's just casey doesn't read it it
doesn't translate got it so we don't
have to figure out yeah casey's flirting
style okay no then it's cute because
okay we'll get it anyway all right
number one it says if they look directly
at you while talking to their friend
it's a good sign yeah yeah
um i remember reading and i found this
to be true if you're in a group and
something funny happens the first person
you look at when you're laughing it's
usually the person
that you like so sometimes i'll catch in
a group like when someone's laughing
these two people just always look at
each other when they're laughing yes and
i noticed that too i think that's in
here actually yeah yeah there's probably
a couple things because body language
you can always tell eye contact because
it's that whole energy exchange yeah
also like if somebody is mm-hmm
and just another group setting type
thing to see if someone's interested in
you they'll copy your body language
without like subconscious yeah so yeah
but the eye contact there's nothing
worse than when you're trying to be
funny and the person you're trying to
impress doesn't look at you
i have this thing that i do um
and i do it on purpose too especially
with like guys who are taller than me um
it's called the doe eyes
so when i look at them and i'm just like
talking or they're talking to me i just
look at him like
yeah that's how you look at me and then
yeah exactly because i'm taller than me
i know
it's the dough i look and then it's so
funny because it actually works really
well i've um i've done that to you guys
in the middle there they're like when
they're talking and they'll just be like
and they'll just like kind of stumble
over the words a little bit i think it's
the cutest thing yeah yeah that's
another thing it's like how do you
receive flirting because i just get
weird
yeah i'm just like that didn't happen
right like i don't know
just like i don't know i get weird
i'm like what what's going on how do i
receive this and how do i
people reciprocate different flirting
things differently right well if you're
trying to flirt with somebody that you
want them to flirt back that one right
so
it depends it really depends on the
person i think that's like the biggest
takeaway from whatever everyone hears
today it depends on the person because
the doe eyes
it's cute
i'd be like oh you're flirty like that's
sweet
but that wouldn't get me to the next
place it'd be like oh i can obviously
tell you're flirting but it's like okay
that's cute but for some people that's
like oh wow like i'm i'm stuck for me i
love a low like the low eyes so if
somebody's kind of flirting with me my
whole energy changes like if i'm into
that person and i want them to continue
to flirt then i'm gonna probably start
mirroring some of the things or i'm
going to feed into it like if you're
looking at me a type of way i'm going to
look at you a type of way so it's like
we'll just use gina as an example since
you guys see us flirt all the time
so if gina's giving me dough eyes and
i'm wanting her to know like i am
flirting back with you i'm never like
don't flirt with my mom right he's like
i probably would actually end up doing
the same thing or like if she's going
doughy and i'm thinking more sexy um
just because that's more of my style
then i'll probably like hit her with
like a low hmm she'll be like giving me
like a soft baby girl look and i'm gonna
be like where are you playing with me
but that's my approach because i'm a
little bit more you know like more
sexual yeah in my flirting
because i'm like okay this is what we're
doing okay
okay i see you
so it just depends also if you want to
keep it fun
and light
it's the
sticker
versus if like you're flirting with me
i'm like oh wow it's gonna be like
yeah maybe a lot more subtle um tone
changes in the voice a lot of body
language changes environment environment
right so most of the time we're very fun
and light and flirty and we're keeping
it that way but if i'm trying to take
this girl home
and she looking at me that way
i'm like all right
see sasha's giggling because that's how
i'm putting it i'm making her nervous
and that's how you can tell if somebody
is wanting you to continue to flirt with
them because their body language becomes
more open
and they're not like as awkward if
somebody is clamming up when you are
attempting to flirt with them they are
uncomfortable yep do not make people
uncomfortable so if that's your
technique and you're like oh [ __ ] it's
not working adjust
you can keep okay it's gonna turn off
the light hey oh hey
[Laughter]
but yes okay so so yeah that is okay i
find that um like in the beginning of
the day that's when i give them the
dough ice but if we do like if we're
going to dinner oh we're going to dinner
and it's like a nice
oh that's a different that's a different
energy i've got my wine cup those that's
when the low eyes come in
because you're sitting straight next to
each other
yeah and this is also a situation where
you're with this person this isn't like
i'm trying to flirt to get your
attention
depending on the circumstances true it
really really depends because that's a
completely different style yeah because
say
we
like kitty what are you doing
what was uh can you repeat what number
one was what they it was eye contact eye
contact so we'll give a more like light
situation probably a scenario most
people are in say you want to flirt with
um somebody at work we'll just use work
as an example and um the eye contact
after somebody tells a joke or you know
you're looking at them it's a really
subtle way of trying to let someone know
that i'm paying attention to you it's
not obvious flirting but it is a way to
have you know like i'm acknowledging
what you're saying i'm being attentive
and
hopefully this can help let you know
that i am here right and i'm hearing you
which for a lot of people that's
extremely sexy so the attention is a
part of the flirting that's true yeah
that's a good tip
number two good at flirting also means
recognizing when the other party isn't
receptive if they're answering briskly
and killing conversation cut your losses
and move on yeah see this is the part
where i'm like
if i was the person receiving flirting
i feel like this is how i would react
but i'm not trying to cut them off just
that i'm awkward and like uncomfortable
and like uncomfortable but like not in a
negative way like i
you know what i mean like i know there's
a lot of people out to know exactly what
i'm talking about but how do you receive
the flirting when you're just awkward
and like when you're wanting that when
you want them to continue flirting
let me i just want to clarify the
situation so you're uncomfortable you're
awkward because you don't know how to
accept like compliments and things like
that you can
this is if this person is who you're
wanting to flirt with you you can kind
of be
a little apologetic like oh
yeah sorry i'm a little you know like
like no it's not you i'm just i'm just a
little awkward but you're letting them
know like i'm receiving
it um in my own way
you're not wrong you kind of gotta let
them know like i'm liking what you're
doing i'm just not used to it yeah um
but please don't stop so however it is
that you want to communicate that
because yes if you are like
if you're looking scared
and the person continues to flirt that
would com that should confuse the person
who is flirting right like you're
looking scared if you look scared like
uh save me like don't continue pressing
the flirt but if you're like the awkward
person um like i guess smiling is a big
big key component right because in the
eye
i'm picturing myself in that situation
and then i'm like i'm definitely smiling
a lot yeah
but
here's another one that's really
confusing when i'm receiving something
flirting from a person i don't want to i
don't want them to flirt with me i don't
know how to reject and i'm smiling so
it's [ __ ] confusing
women are taught to
like be like oh don't get the man you're
angry like yeah yeah you're taught to be
nice don't make a scene when i was like
yeah yeah okay thank you thank you but
i'll say eye contact that goes right
back to eye contact you have to have a
level of comfort with that person to
look them in the face to make eye
contact so if you're
awkwardly smiling but looking down
you're giving off that you're shy which
should also indicate that you're not
interested because if someone's not
looking you in the eye they're either
hiding something or they're um they're
hiding what they're feeling uh so say
you nervous laugh you know you nervous
laugh but if you're like looking down
and you still kind of make eye contact
like oh i'm nervous but i'm looking at
you i'm still
engaged
if i'm looking down and i'm like
you're flirting and i don't want it to
continue i'm not looking at you i might
laugh i'm looking away i'm obviously
avoiding your face and i'm avoiding your
eyes so that you can understand it's the
i'm politely um not accepting
yeah your gestures right but if i'm
nervous and
i'm into you i'm still gonna kind of
look at you yeah and i'm still gonna be
kind of facing you that's true ninety
percent of communication is non-verbal
pay attention yep there we go um my
thing is i just vocalize it because
there have been some guys where i can't
even look at them when they talk to me
and like because i just get so shy and
i'll actually say it straight up like in
the middle of his uh while i'm talking
to him i i will be talking i'm like
look listen you are so
i can't look at you because you make me
so nervous yeah so you're vocalizing it
so they know like okay you're verbally
floating yeah learning at that point and
accepting yeah you're accepting it
you're like okay
i like what you put in nothing but i
can't look at you yeah i should do what
you vocalize it so there's no confusion
at all yeah yeah okay
next one
does their body turn towards you or away
from you when you talk do they mirror
your body language exactly what blaze
was talking about
yeah yeah um like if we're like if we're
talking face-to-face like i'm making
sure my toes are pointed at you my
body's pointed at you
um you actually like consciously think
about that oh yeah oh because i totally
don't well the reason too is like
we know how we know how to flirt right
so say and a lot of people we're going
to use i'll use instagram as an example
or just taking photos um models you
always hear the like the photographer
like make love to the camera and do this
and do that and what we're doing is
we're flirting we're changing our body
language we're changing our our mindset
in order to portray a feeling so when
you're doing those things it like if
anything it's uh more conscious that
like yes i know how to flirt because i
know what it looks like because i've
seen it
um i've practiced it right so i know
what the person is uh receiving but say
you don't and you're not really like a
camera person or you're not really like
an actor or someone that has to show
their emotions as obviously
it's going to be extremely different for
you to to think that and that's why
subconsciously a lot of the times our
body um
reacts to people
and it does it without us even thinking
about it so if you're in a room uh
and you have somebody that you like your
body just kind of naturally
gravitates towards them there's certain
mannerisms that you do the way you face
but if somebody is like
intentionally trying to flirt with you
and is aware of that that's why you can
point at somebody like you're a flirt
because you can tell that that person
knows exactly what they're doing to get
you to feel a type of way
so that's why subtle movements uh for
people who are not
as like you know as obvious with their
flirting is really important and what to
pay attention to yeah
okay um
yeah i face towards them and then there
does come become like there's there is a
mimicking thing and it does happen
naturally when you like someone but then
i since we
like we know what we're doing i do it
intentionally also if he grabs his drink
to drink i'm gonna grab my drink to
drink if he's sitting with his elbows on
the table so am i
um and then like the hair touching you
know or like or i'll just find an excuse
to touch you it's like oh my god look
how funny that is you know like just
like a quick something like that yeah so
to somebody who is not
trained in flirting i mean anybody in
hospitality oh my god if you ever think
that your waiter or your bartender or
somebody that's in the service industry
is really flirting with you they
probably are but it might not be for the
romantic intention it is a part of the
job you really do need to be aware
that's why sometimes was like you gave
the waitress how much of a tip or oh
when guys are like oh the bartender
wants me yeah she does she wants your
money right she also knows how to flirt
with you she's a professional be aware
of that they know how to listen they
know how to adapt they know how to do
that so say you're out and you're not
trained in those things picking up on
the hand placement you're so funny
little physical touch right physical
touch also placement of the hand um
somebody
ladies and gentlemen depending on where
you put your hand on someone when you're
attempting to flirt does change it from
being flirting to being like sexual yeah
and it can really make a situation
become uncomfortable
for the person receiving it so
yes we naturally like this
sub girl
so
the hug say you give up
and you're trying to figure out if
somebody that you know is flirting with
you placement of the hand in the hug
will show you so most people when
they're hugging you and they want to
keep it friendly hands are always up
always above the waist and it's a tap
it's never a long embrace never a long
embrace oh especially if there's a pet
on the back yes that's a friendship
on the back i'm not flirting with you so
don't mistake my hug
because some people can't mistake a hug
for flirting as that's just how i greet
people hi hug pat pat friend family do
not read into the pet
hug in hand
longer if you can feel the hand that's
them trying to show you something i
don't know whether
yeah definitely
i'll be like do i have something on my
heart
you rub it in my lotion
but like you know a hug is a really is
why a lot of people use the club like
why a lot of people be like why do you
hug that girl for so long
because there are certain things that
you just do when you're flirting and
when you don't do when you're not
flirting so the long embrace is kind of
like
what are we doing the pat is friendly
the huh one arm yeah the oh you're funny
and you tap them on the arm
i'm letting you know i'm again it's all
signs to show you that i'm interested
i'm paying attention to you and once you
incorporate the physical touch in now
there's like a connection but say
when we record and you tap me on my leg
you're not doing it to flirt with me
because it's not you're doing it to like
you're engaging you're like i'm letting
you know but if you like if i was
sitting here i was talking to gina and
i'd just be like
and just like put like a finger or just
whatever
yes then that's more of flirting yeah
exactly unzip a little bit
i wore this outfit i already knew what
we were doing today
today's episode is sponsored by honey
the easy way to save when shopping on
your iphone or computer thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past honey is the free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best one
it finds to your cart so here's how it
works when you're shopping on one of
your favorite sites at checkout the
honey button appears and all you have to
do is click apply coupons then you wait
a few seconds as honey searches for
coupons it can find for that site if
honey finds a working coupon you'll
watch the prices drop also honey doesn't
just work on your desktop it works on
your iphone too just activate it on
safari on your phone and save on the go
i remember shopping like i use this all
the time because it's so easy and plus
it's free i'll be shopping for clothes
and when i check out i hit the honey
button and it finds every code and it'll
give me codes for like 20 off for new
customers or something like that or like
a holiday promo it's awesome so if you
don't already have honey you could be
straight up missing out and by getting
it you'll be doing yourself a solid in
supporting this show get honey for free
at joinhoney.com
big mood that's joinhoney.com
big mood if you have a baby with
sensitive skin or even eczema you know
how difficult it is when they develop a
diaper rash enter coterie coterie
diapers and wipes are made with the most
gentle and safe materials to help your
baby stay comfortable and you at ease i
am such a ginormous fan of this diaper
brand i can't even tell you i cannot
express how much i love coterie diapers
they are so luxuriously like feeling and
they actually keep my baby nice and dry
and comfortable throughout the whole day
and night so the last time i talked
about cautery diapers i said i had left
luca and then for about five
hours and now i'm honestly leaving him
the entire time he's sleeping he's
asleep from 7 00 p.m to 7 a.m and he
wakes up and he's completely comfortable
he's not complaining there are no
blowbacks no leaks i cannot rave about
these diapers enough they are amazing
coterie is the highest performing diaper
on the market for infants and toddlers
with up to two times more liquid
capacity and up to four times faster
moisture wicking versus other brands
your baby stays dryer longer and coterie
parents report fewer nighttime diaper
changes like i do which can lead to
better sleep quality not just for your
baby but for you too and i can attest to
this you guys casey and i are sleeping
through the night it's amazing luca only
wakes up once to eat at 4 00 am
no diaper change is needed i am such a
huge fan coterie diapers are made with
clothing grade material giving your baby
a cashmere like feel so they're more
comfortable for longer they are
dermatologists tested and use only the
cleanest ingredients plus coterie wipes
are national eczema association approved
coterie has been awarded best diaper and
wipes by both the bump and parrots.com
and actually you know how i started off
by talking about diaper rashes luca has
not had a diaper rash since using
coterie i'm mind blown i mean he's only
four months old now but
he has not had he's only had a few
diaper rashes with other diapers but
with coterie ever since we switched not
one single diaper rash i love it and
right now coterie is partnering with our
podcast to offer you 20 off your first
order plus free shipping at codery.com
big mood that's codery spelled
c-o-t-e-r-i-e dot com slash big mood for
20 off and free shipping codery.com
big mood okay the next one here it says
exactly what you're talking about
physical contact granted not everyone
flirts the same way but a good sign is
if they touch your arm or the like or if
you find them smiling the whole time
that you're talking to them a romantic
gesture
when you're on a date the subtle subtle
touch on the hand does so much
it's really about being soft and um the
approach that you're taking to that
person when guys are like i didn't know
she was flirting with me because maybe
her approach is very you know very soft
and and subtle but like a woman we
know
whether i'm flirting with a girl i'm
flirting with a guy whatever's going on
if there's something with the hand that
is so intimate and it like eye contact
plus a touch on the hand it's like oh
that's where you kind of go like oh wow
like this is
yeah you know like you kind of like wow
that's really sweet and those are like
the moments that stick with people yeah
the obvious over like the touch on the
thigh like look we we we [ __ ] if you
touch my thighs
that's either what you're thinking or
what i'm thinking because that's way too
sexual it's way too obvious yeah
that's not what you want to do at all so
it's the nice little you know talking
about physical touch like that's pretty
much so the way that
that i've really i don't intentionally
do this but i've noticed
in the way that when i'm trying to flirt
with casey i end up tickling him for
something
or like i'll just be like dumb or
whatever you know but then but then i'm
kind of like
not
cute flirty about it i'm more like
pesteringly about it but that like some
schoolyard [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah but
that's probably like what you saw or how
you don't even know where i got that
from but then i don't even realize i'm
doing anything
with me
she likes me
together and then so it like casey's
obviously not receiving that as like oh
she's flirting he's just like i don't
like being tickled stop tickling me
right so i'm like [ __ ] sorry but then
his way of flirting is like he does this
thing he's like
yeah i got something in my eye
like play it off like that but it just
feels so silly to flirt but then we i
don't intentionally do it but that's
cute it works for you yeah it's like
funny
but that's what flirting is like
learning isn't just supposed to be like
i'm trying to get you in my bed flirting
is showing interest it's whatever makes
you feel good it's it's light like it is
so different if you're trying to seduce
it's very different than flirting to
seduce someone there's a whole art of
seduction for a reason and everybody's
style is different yeah and i
do the like smack i'm a little bit
rougher i'm a lot rougher honestly um
when i was so funny
[Music]
yeah i had a hard time receiving like
subtle
flirting i didn't it just didn't i it
didn't register with me i didn't really
find it like you know sexy or whatever
because of [ __ ] from before but i
understand because i know and i've just
like studied it like okay i see what
you're doing but like if i'm genuinely
flirting with someone and i'm really
into you and you're into me and we're
being cute when that's what i think of
flirting i think of flirting as it's
it's cute it's playful it's light it
makes you feel
not just wanted physically but like when
you're flirting with somebody it's like
i'm into all of you as a person
um like i use the pokemon excuse like
any time for me if you make me laugh and
you're if you make me hear if you make
me laugh and you're not making fun of me
yeah do you know what i mean if i'm not
the butt of the joke i don't some people
do flirt that right wait right that old
school kind of like
making fun of you and they're like
and i'm like [ __ ] i don't like that
yeah it's not working but if somebody
like
if they're i just like a good sense of
humor
and they know that it's gonna make me
laugh because they've paid attention
that to me is like that's flirting
that's what's going to actually work
yeah and uh you make me laugh
yes
i would just i'd tell one story but i
don't know if i'm ready to tell you but
yeah
that's
somebody made me like laugh and the way
that they flirted with me i was like oh
[ __ ] i like you yeah you know like it
was not sexy at all but it was just
flirting and it was silly and i was like
holy [ __ ]
now i'm nervous
and people don't make me nervous and i
was like
yeah
i like
i like you
all right uh and then this next one is
what you were saying earlier gina about
like if someone looks at you after
someone else in the group or it doesn't
have to be you says something funny and
everyone's laughing and they look at you
that's it
yeah that's a clear sign right there
yeah um this other one says seriously
tell a bad joke look for laughter and
smiles that should not be there but are
then they are into you
yeah because i can tell you
when people are not into you and it
[ __ ] sucks because that is a great
way be in a room full of co-workers you
want to know who likes you even as a
person not even necessarily flirting
with you but yes who actually likes you
say something and watch who doesn't
react yeah
and that's why so many people have more
of that awkward feeling because you can
clearly tell when people don't like you
and then once you can identify that then
you can see when somebody is interested
and then you can tell when somebody is
flirting but the eye contact man they
will let you know if they do not want
you to talk anymore
and that will let you know who actually
is nice
you'll be like okay yeah cool yeah i
knew a girl once um
who like we were all in a group setting
and then like i didn't like anyone there
but like when i'm laughing i'm just like
kind of you know looking at the group
and then i realized her boyfriend kept
looking at me every time he laughs and i
was like oh no yeah that's not good yeah
ah nah i'm good yeah
yeah and it's little things like that
it's all subconscious a lot of it but
really flirting has to do with attention
that's where it all starts so body
language the eye contact it's about
being comfortable yeah it's trying to
let the person know i'm paying attention
to you and then
the sign that's really what is and
that's why people get confused on is
this person flirting with me or are they
just paying attention to me
and that's why
it can get weird at times like oh i
didn't know you were flirting i thought
that you were just
not being a shitty person yeah so then
you get into like the next phases of
like when the physical touch comes in
and then like yeah ladies and gentlemen
if you don't want somebody to think
you're flirting with them don't touch
them yeah
but if you do it's the
just try not to right i think that's
like that's a big way so so if you're
touching someone whether you know guy or
girl
and then you're like oh no i don't
understand why you feel that way why are
you thinking that i'm flirting with you
you have to understand you did that like
you
you
got into their bubble you got into their
space and most people will think that
that is flirting
yeah it's true they had there have been
instances where um
by me just being
friendly or like just smiling and
being interested in to what they're
saying
they'd end up like i remember a lot of
this happened in high school like they
would actually tell me like hey so
whatever they'll make a move and i'm
like
how did we get here yeah and that's why
it gets
difficult because there are some times
where you are just like hey i might like
you as a person it doesn't mean that i
want to be with you
but
that's where a lot of people get
confused because it's like damn you're
giving me attention i feel seen i feel
hurt
and just that acknowledgement is
so much but when you get into depending
on what you're talking about
that can also make it seem as though
you're flirting with that person um the
setting has a big part to do with that
i suggest anybody that's going on a date
for the first time or getting to meet
someone to never do dinner never do
dinner um never do dinner keep it with
like coffee or something like a jew
something like a snack like right where
the conversation is the main focus um
anything that's in an evening
automatically leads you towards
something romantic and leads to the
assumption that there might be something
after and
i'm sorry my doorbell just won't be yeah
is there something it's probably the
food oh wow that's nice
um
so and that can and that can lead to it
why
workplaces aren't necessarily the most
romantic spots is because it's not
supposed to create a romantic
environment yeah and that's why flirting
in the workplace looks different than
flirting at a bar at a club intention
yeah i know that i
am naturally a very flirty person even
if i don't mean to but it's just i just
like talking to people and you also like
touching a lot i like touching i'm a
very touchy person i know it comes off
for people who aren't really used to it
it might come off as oh she's flirting
with me and i can usually tell when
they're starting to think that i'm
flirting with them and that's when i
throw in like yeah me and my boyfriend
are going off to you know whatever
even if i don't have a boyfriend just
because so so they know you know um like
i had someone in the workplace before
just suddenly asked me for my number and
i was like okay
yeah you know like we've had plenty of
conversations like just surface level
before
um but it just so happens on that day of
that shoot i was wearing something real
tight yeah
and so after work he asked me for my
number and i was like oh crap okay here
we go and he's like yeah so you know
what are you doing this weekend i just
straight up said oh me and my man are
going out to some dinner they get some
dinner you know just cut that off real
quick yeah yeah how do you react oh he
goes oh cool cool
to
to accept rejection too is an is an art
form oh it's an art form and there are a
lot of people that i've encountered that
like gina said sometimes
all the time i naturally am more flirty
unless i'm blatantly trying to let you
know i'm not interested in you or my
whole body language is giving that off
but um i've had you know when guys ask
for your number things like that like
i'm not even flirting with you but
sometimes they'll just try
you know they're flirting with me
they're shooting their shot and if i'm
like i'm sorry you know i'm not
interested just you know thank you i
appreciate that or when i get the oh
you're so beautiful i was like oh i
really appreciate that thank you but you
know sorry i'm not interested and
there's nothing
better than understanding like okay she
obviously isn't interested in me there's
nothing wrong with that there's nothing
wrong with somebody not liking you
understand that not everyone's gonna
like you that is okay and once you learn
that and you can be like okay hey i'm
giving you the compliment because i
genuinely wanted to give you a
compliment
and it's not because i'm trying to
manipulate you they just go
no problem yeah i think you're beautiful
i just wanted to let you know that okay
have a good day yeah and that's so
appreciative like appreciate that a lot
and then also if i'm flirting with
somebody
unintentionally i'd be like oh [ __ ]
instead like sometimes i'll just be like
my bad like hey i i know i kind of get
like that sometimes i'm not trying to
yeah you know do that intentionally i
understand how it comes off i mean
that's like the adult way i think
because then there's also those
scenarios where it's like all right then
[ __ ] you're not even that cute anyway
you've got to learn how to accept
rejection gracefully otherwise you look
like a little [ __ ] yeah but then
that reaction is because they don't mean
what they're saying to you if you become
extremely offended
you
don't have the best intentions for that
person so if you are actually interested
in a man or a woman and you gave the
compliment
and you wanted to get to know them and
all of a sudden because they didn't that
just shows more about you than it does
for that person because you should be
able to understand they're like oh okay
damn i wouldn't want anybody who doesn't
want me
some people think it's a challenge
no like you have to at least communicate
something to let people know like i'm
not interested
but there is an art to turning down
someone and there's an art of accepting
rejection it's very difficult and it's
so ego-based and that is what people
need to learn how to do
because i know i
it doesn't feel good when somebody
doesn't like you
it doesn't so
and you gotta learn how to reject
nicely too like unless a guy just comes
up to me he's gross yeah and you can you
can be like nah i'm good like whatever
but if someone's like hey you know i
yeah i think you're really pretty you're
like uh no no thank you it's like dude
don't be a [ __ ] about it yeah i make it
a point to like if someone approaches me
very nicely and i'm not
um interested i'm like i'm sorry i'm you
know i'm i'm not really interested but
thank you so much like that's actually
really sweet of you and sometimes i'm
like um it's you know it's really cool
that you actually like came up to me and
talked to me that's actually really
chill so good luck out there and we have
to have like
it's almost like we have to create this
uh universal
sign of like if i say i'm not interested
it doesn't mean keep trying yeah don't
don't abuse that though because i know
some people play hard to get oh but we
can't be friends right
or even you know if if you turn somebody
down like if we're all ladies and
gentlemen if we are deciding that if we
tell somebody we like no thank you
please actually mean that and use that
as a flirting technique that's why
people get confused because if you know
you're being taught like keep trying or
you have to pursue her and somebody's
like no please actually i don't
actually i really
am not interested
please don't like we have to understand
if you no means no
but we have to make no me know yeah yeah
you have to make no me know yeah we have
to and that's why some people are
aggressive with turning it down because
they've said the no and it didn't work
and that sucks because we're
we're all just reacting to what we're
used to
and there have been times i'd be like
hey what the [ __ ] are you looking at
like knock it off like now you're just
you're making me become somebody that i
don't want to be because of what i've
gone through i've told men no i've told
women no and they didn't accept it and
i'm like i'm not flirting with you i'm
pleased get away from me and they're
just like
because of their experiences
that somehow worked for them but if i
have to become aggressive i don't want
to but sometimes it literally is for
your safety
and it shouldn't be
as
traumatizing to flirt right
it shouldn't be but if we're gonna say
no let's be like okay cool if she come
back around or he come back around
that's on them you know you're talking
about that
and um you're talking about the fact
that
there's people that say no but then it
ends up turning into a yes yeah i've
been that person and it comes from a
place of like
not having the confidence to fully
walk away or turn down the person or
like i've been in situations where like
it's like me and the dude alone in the
car
and
we're supposed to like head to a party
we don't go to somehow like all the
parties canceled some [ __ ] happens and
i'm just like i'm scared i'm like [ __ ] i
don't know how to
get out of this situation yeah then i'm
now in and then i just i just give in
i'm like
okay fine
yeah and just gotta teach you know
are
you know girls and boys as kids to be
assertive with what you want what you
don't want yeah and i understand that
you have were
not really that type of person before
you don't know how to say no to people
no i was into into the tiff yeah that's
what i was called because yeah like i
somehow get myself into situations where
i'm like
how the [ __ ] did this happen like how
did i allow this
the pressure of it
yeah and it's tough i'm glad we're
having a conversation about flirting but
also
what happens when you don't want someone
to flirt with you or what happens when
you realize like oh oh [ __ ] i
i didn't want it to take this turn now
you're evaluating the steps that you
took and you're like [ __ ]
damn it i think i led i led us to this
point there are a lot of situations to
where sometimes we don't realize that
that's what we're doing and we're like
uh oh uh oh yeah but i gave off that's
why this person is interpreting it this
way that's why he's assuming we're about
to have sex that's why you know we're in
situations like oh no i'm in too deep
and
being aware of ourselves um our body
language what somebody is probably
assuming
it's a learning curve and so many of us
have been in situations where i was like
yeah i thought that this was good and i
thought that this is where i wanted to
be and oh [ __ ] i don't want to be here
this is i'm actually uncomfortable and
we have to teach men and women to be
like okay now the ego is involved boom
you're in a situation you're horny
or that person is into it whatever there
should be a line for where when i say
nowhere i'm not forcing this upon
someone else and we have to acknowledge
that but it is such a hormonal thing and
the ego is attached to like some other
part of our brain that is very
triggering and people react
dramatically with rejection or with um
like i fear fear yeah and for a lot of
people they close in and they don't know
how to speak and they get me and you
know they know me i guess that currently
is me because kind of like what was
happening in the hospital situation
giving birth to luca like i felt old
tiff yeah
like i couldn't i couldn't yes
and realistically we don't know how
we're going to react in situations
unless we've played out these scenarios
it's like the fight freeze or flight or
flight yeah and a lot of times we hear
about
people that are in situations they don't
want to be in and they didn't say
anything and then they talk after and
people go why didn't you say something
then well like the aziz
aziz i'm sorry
i can't
yeah like what happened with him like
that that was similar to his situation
yeah the girl later came out and she was
like yeah i wasn't comfortable but she
didn't say anything
and
that makes it hard we're not in each
other's brains right uh we don't know
what somebody's thinking we don't know
what someone's intentions are and if we
don't communicate that that's how we end
up whether the person didn't know they
were doing that because we're just like
how did you not how couldn't you tell
like
nobody said anything yeah and
as we continue to talk about it we have
to be like it's okay you have to speak
up because if i'm like get the [ __ ] off
me and you don't get the [ __ ] off of me
what happens next you've already been
warned yeah you've i've let you know
very clearly but because i've been in
situations where i didn't say that
and i and i have to live with that
feeling i don't allow that to happen
again yeah but unfortunately unless
you've gone through it you don't know
what you're gonna do when it happens
right so you have to play these
scenarios out and hey my dad um and my
mom
made it very clear like
you
have to understand
what you look like
what what you dress like is gonna get a
certain amount of attention people are
gonna assume things about you they're
gonna like i
had to think the worst a lot but
it did put me in a state of mind that i
always knew what somebody was probably
thinking
that they wanted to do and i took it
upon myself to know
hey
it's not going to happen
and that's not me trying to be mean
that's just me being clear right so you
don't get confused by
whatever you are turned on by right now
yeah but it [ __ ]
sucks to have to assume that but
when you do and people are understanding
like yeah you probably went that person
probably went through something really
traumatic
that's where we need to get to like hey
let's respect each other but
no got me no yeah no no no exactly no me
no huge tech companies in america pay
next to nothing in taxes meaning they
barely give anything back to society
that makes them rich they may not do a
lot of giving but they sure do a lot of
taking ladies and gentlemen i'm talking
about these tech companies that enrich
themselves by taking your personal data
they grab your web history email
metadata and video searches to create a
detailed profile on you and then sell
that off to the highest bidder companies
just aren't selling products anymore
they're selling you you have become the
product to protect your identity and
data from these tech giants i recommend
using espresso vpn every time you go
online so think about all the websites
that you visit facebook twitter google
everything you do or say online is
tracked by these giant corporations
using your public ip address they can
uniquely match your activity and your
known location expressvpn makes you
anonymous online by camouflaging your ip
address and replacing it with a
different secure ip of your choice
expressvpn also encrypts all your data
so that it protects from hackers and
anyone else that's trying to spy on you
and what i like the most about it is
that it is so easy to use you just
download the app on your phone or your
computer tap one button and you're
protected so if you're like me and
believe your internet data belongs to
you and not to greedy corporations then
expressvpn is the answer personally i
use it just because i want to keep my
data safe i don't
want someone knowing so much about me
out there i think it's so creepy protect
your data with the number one rated vpn
provider today visit expressvpn.com big
mood to get three months free on a one
year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
big mood again that's
expressvpn.com to learn more in the last
few years we've had to cancel a few too
many get-togethers with friends but not
this year we're back baby and it's time
to party return like a hero with
something delicious from milk bar james
beard award-winning celebrity chef
christina tosi opened the first milk bar
in 2008 and she's been wowing the world
and not to mention her celebrity friends
with her unique spin on iconic flavors
ever since milk bar is a perfect gift
for anyone and everyone in your life
from birthdays to graduations to summer
cookouts or just because a few of milk
bars best sellers include their
signature birthday cake with unfrosted
sides the salty sweet compost cookie
milk bar pie made from toasted oat crust
with a gooey butter filling and for a
limited time milk bar is offering their
delicious new strawberry shortcake and
cake truffles which is the thing that i
ordered and oh my god is it amazing oh
the hype is real on this one too you
guys milk bar is so good it's like not
too sweet and like perfectly moist oh my
god you guys gotta try it every milk bar
creation is made fresh then thoughtfully
and beautifully packaged so it arrives
in perfect condition ready to enjoy they
offer fast even overnight nationwide
delivery right now milk bar has a
special limited time offer
get ten dollars off any order of fifty
dollars or more when you go to
slash big milkbarstore.com
you'll get ten bucks off an order of
fifty dollars by going to milk bar store
dot com slash big mood don't forget
check out milk bar store dot com slash
big mood and get some yummies
the next one on this list it says
i remember going on nine dates of the
girl who just who just got out of a long
relationship and just wanted to be
friends to which i said cool let's just
hang out then one night she was dropping
me off at my place after a movie she
turned the car off and put her arm on my
head rest as we chatted before i got out
i was fully in the mindset that we were
just friends so i shook her hand good
night
so someone's like saying her like their
experience of when someone else was
flirting with them but yeah it's like
going back to what you were saying about
how confusing it is where it's like she
already said she didn't want this one
thing but then now she's making the
moves
it develops it can develop over time but
it is hard when there was an already
initial thing like hey i don't want
anything but then after spending nine
dates together maybe she started feeling
something you know yeah um but that's
where communication becomes a big thing
too
you know and if he was confused like
there you can always just
text or caller and be like hey i don't
know if i'm reading into this too much
do you still just want to be friends
because i got kind of a flirt like just
tell me if i'm wrong or not yeah so that
it doesn't make things even more awkward
i feel like communication is so good so
that you don't keep extending like this
awkward what the hell is going on yeah
that's right you know yeah but he was
and he respected her yeah it's better to
be like hey
i'm just respecting what you told me if
this girl got upset yeah
she's the problem yes oh yeah she's the
problem in this scenario if she becomes
upset because he didn't act on her
advances all right because he's just
trying to respect her so if you
establish like things are changing
maybe okay you didn't act on the first
one she does it again then you can kind
of be
are you are you flirting with me yeah is
but he also has to know like
is that what you want
he's now the one that's uncomfortable by
this we don't know if that's really you
know how is he feeling that
so [ __ ] confusing but the
communication happens after i'm glad he
didn't go for that because that could be
a trick yo not everybody out there has
the best intentions in the situation men
and women she just manipulated him right
like that was a whole manipulative
situation she was like i want to be
friends with you but you're going on
dates with him you're not just kicking
it y'all are going on dates yeah why are
you going on dates with this man if you
just want to be friends that's cool then
y'all are hanging out but if you're
putting yourself in romantic situations
and making it that's confusing
that's a super confusing scenario and
i'm happy
he did not
act on it and now he can decide like is
that what he wants to do and plus
he can have a conversation with her and
get the consent so there isn't confusion
yeah and it doesn't ruin a friendship
yeah exactly that could for sure ruin a
friendship and also have a reputation
too
and then if it goes south it's pretty
bad yeah it really does like with a lot
of things most things in life
communication is key like i had one guy
who was like he was very clear that he
liked me and said hey my birthday's come
up i'd really love to spend it with you
and i'm like
you should probably spend it with your
friends and family and i told them
straight i'm like i think that's a
little bit too much because we're just
friends like
i know that you have feelings for me you
told me already um but i already said
that i just wanted to be friends so
spending your birthday with me is just
solely on me just depending on me too
much it's romantic it's a lot of
pressure for me that i'm
i don't want to put that effort into
something that i said that was just
friends this is not a just friend
situation right yeah you should probably
spend your birthday with your friends
and your family yeah you know
yeah that's true it's like recognizing
it and putting a stop to it yeah
all right this next one it says a few
examples of things that have helped give
away someone's feelings for me is
telling their friends about me
remembering my schedule or other similar
information telling me about their
previous interests with striking
similarities bragging about themselves
in ways that would make a potential
partner happy for example i give great
back massages or i cook a mean omelet
asking what my plans are at the end of
the party slash gathering instead of
their friends looking for or grasping
into shared interests oh totally if i'm
trying to see if somebody actually likes
me not just flirting i mean
again i'm pretty i can pick up the signs
if someone's flirting with me but if
someone likes me now we're going to take
it to a next step it is the talking
about future plans
it's the very like again it's all about
interest it's like the oh it's so sad
like oh you remembered that about me
that's like yeah cause that person likes
you
um but the oh yeah like when you start
bragging about yourself to like big
yourself up that person is uh yeah
they're they're just peacocking yeah
yeah yeah yeah that is because if or the
opposite of that is the the shy thing or
sometimes you like kind of downplay
yourself because you're not trying to to
be as big or come off um obnoxious or
come off like super obvious where you're
like oh my god no
i'm okay
i'm just i'm just all right at that when
someone's complimenting you sometimes
that's a form of flirting too it's like
being a little bit more um like you know
i know thanks that's nice oh i just
touched my hair that's like that's like
if i'm messing with myself yeah this is
this isn't flirty i'm not flirting with
you right now like i'm just like i'm
actually trying to fix it but if you're
talking to me and i'm just kind of like
yeah
you can tell yeah yeah cause i'm not a
like twirl but i'm kind of like
now i've
become a little bit shy
and i get a little quiet
that's
also a way of kind of seeing if
someone's like interested not just the
obvious flirting true uh it's like oh um
yeah that's you know like how you said
sometimes you awkward flirt yeah so say
you're like i'm giving you a compliment
and i see that you're still kind of like
oh
no
not that funny
it's like it's the type of like it's
if i like i find it if there's a guy
that i like
i tap into my way more feminine side and
that's where the hair touching comes
yeah
the eyes yeah but like in other
situations like at work whatever i'm a
very masculine energy and that's so
that's how i know i like someone and
someone that is like someone i actually
want to be with because it it makes me
want to be my feminine
um self to show him like hey
you know
a little cute thing i realize depending
on who i'm flirting with
like if i'm flirting with gina if i'm
flirting with a woman i'm way more
masculine i am there's something
i don't really change like whatever i'm
looking like but i can become i'd be
tapped more into that i've noticed that
when i do flirt with women it is coming
from that place like a more masculine
energy i'm not as obvious or i'm a
little bit more subtle it's a little
more cool um it's like i like gina of
course like if you've seen us flirt
gina's gonna be the soft one
like gina isn't being like what's up i'm
like whoa what the [ __ ] like hey
you know but i can go like what's up
you're gonna be like
yeah and it's just like that that energy
exchange but when i'm you know flirting
with a guy i'm like oh maka
because i don't find um super feminine
energy
from a man as attractive um so say
somebody's kind of being soft with me
i'm gonna be like well i don't know yet
yeah but i like someone that is is soft
enough that's funny um that goes into
like what i find attractive so most of
the people that i can clearly tell
they're flirting with me that i'm
wanting to reciprocate is the like
softer but still masculine side if a
woman is flirting with me it's normally
like oh you like the
like i'm like more
assertive a little bit more flirty like
i'm giving off the male energy that or
masculine energy that you like because i
look like i could protect you
yeah you know what i'm saying like if we
go now i'll be like hey
yeah
she don't like it
yeah you make me feel small
i love that yeah and i
yeah same yeah and being
bisexual and i'm attracted to feminine
women i love like
pretty girls i find them extremely sexy
i realize that i take on that role but i
also love the mothering aspect in return
i love being taken care of i love being
catered i love being babied whether it's
male or female but i notice that in a
situation whenever there are women
involved it is always like i'm a little
bit more
masculine but i'm still feminine at the
same time but you know
i'm gonna take care of you i give off
the energy like no one's gonna mess with
you you're gonna feel safe with me i'm
gonna make sure you're okay i'm gonna do
all the things that most women want men
to do
and i
have that mentality too when i'm with a
man i'm attracted to how i treat
women like i know what i would want him
to do
for me
so
it just differs and i think being able
to speak on behalf of you don't say
fellas i got you back i don't know how
it is it'll be confusing sometimes okay
be real confusing
um to see what somebody's giving off but
yeah
i
flirt
it's pretty obvious yeah if i'm
interested in you um and especially like
uh could be subtle yeah i'm definitely
both you on and off camera yeah
yeah and she just went to my bedroom and
sprayed her perfume bottle all over my
bed she's like you're not going to
forget me um yes mommy thank you
trust me i know it i know what everybody
likes that's also why i'm a good
flurries because i pay attention to
certain things and i can tell that okay
y'all want to feel a little bit more
secure like you said you like feeling
small
[Applause]
do you think that i'm going to be
cuddled up underneath your arm and
you're like no i'm more likely to let
you like let you flirt with me like i'll
let you know i'm interested but allow
you to again that feminine energy thing
kick back a bit and then you know that's
what i try to do when i'm flirting with
a guy like i'm gonna let you know
i'm gonna do all the little i'm gonna do
all the little things
yeah
this is all great advice you guys
because i don't know i think about it
and every time i try to be flirty i
always get so silly like i can't
it works it can't help but like laugh
and like it and like break it like break
the the
because
again flirting isn't necessarily just to
go and get someone in the bed
to flirt with someone is just a whole
different type of energy you're
exchanging with that person it you can
flirt with somebody and never sleep with
them oh my god i have people i love
[ __ ] flirting with but it doesn't
mean that i want a relationship with you
and it doesn't mean that i want to have
sex with you that is not what i'm giving
off if i am flirting with you it's
normally on the lighter side if i am
interested in you and i am trying to be
sexy
that is because i'm trying to sleep with
you i'm not giggly doing the cutesy [ __ ]
if i'm really wanting to be with you and
that's why depending on who you're
talking to and what your intentions are
really change how you react like the
cute [ __ ] again i've flirted with guys
and be like oh my god i like you
doesn't mean that i want to have sex
with you but it also can lead me to
having a deeper connection so that if
that does happen like it's because i
want more from you than just that yeah
for sure i think flirting is fun and
it's light but it can get really [ __ ]
up if you mislead somebody into
believing that they can get sex with you
what's the what's what's the best ways
cutest sexiest ways anyone's ever
flirted with you guys that you can
remember at the top of your head i told
you he he jokingly called me he like
gave me a pokemon
i was like
oh my god that's so cute like our
conversation was fun he's interesting um
like hilarious and we're just like
really vibing it's not no one's talking
about future plans nobody's talking
about who i want to do this to you or
nothing but it was really the subtle
like joke
and it was the like i'm thinking of
of you and it was just like oh yeah i
can call you my little uh nikachu yeah
and i was like
you want me you want you want to make me
a pokemon
oh that's cute there's a couple other
situations but a lot of it is because
that's um i find humor
and silliness very attractive that's
kind of how you would flirt with me
all the other [ __ ] i'm like i'm trying
to be
yeah that doesn't work but who if you
are silly like you thinking that being
silly isn't flirting
i really hope that you don't
accidentally do that and think you're
not flirting because i would be like
that is so [ __ ] cute
like that is
you make me want to like get to know you
more yeah and that's why there's levels
to flirting there's the i'm trying to
flirt with you to get something from you
and then there's like the flirting like
wow i actually really am interested in
you as a person and that's why um
i'm still like engaged in the
conversation or like oh my i'm changing
because that's silly [ __ ] be like it's
just hella cute any guy that i've ever
really had a crush on did something
silly yeah exactly i did love that
i love i love them dorky
oh i love dorky guys
i i remember the best one that still
sticks out to me this is like in my
mid-20s i was working a convention and a
lot of conventions they have those like
military recruitment do like um this
many pull-ups you know
um so there was that the military booth
was like right across from ours i was
working for pelican cases at the time
and during that they had the recruit
thing they had like a robot like a like
i don't know like a bomb defusing i
don't know but like this multi-million
dollar robot right
and it had a camera on it and then like
we were making eyes you know here like
it was a three-day convention and then
all of a sudden i looked down there's
like this little robot just coming
towards me and clamped in his hand was a
water bottle
and a water bottle was a note and i was
like what and then i look up and the
guys are like
um it's like the white
yeah
and then so i bent down and i grabbed
the note and it says do you like me yes
or no oh my god it was the cutest thing
so
there was camera there so when i bent
down i realized my chest was like right
where the camera was and i was like wait
a minute and i looked up and the guy was
like no no no no that's what i wanted he
was the cutest yeah just a silly you
know yeah he just flirted with me with a
multi-million dollar military role crazy
you know
oh
there's this one time at the gym
and this
this guy played it out perfectly i don't
know if i've already told this story but
i was working out and he tried to strike
up a conversation with me and i'm like
i'm not interested in you sir first off
i'm the worst person to flirt with at
the gym i am aggressive i'm like get the
[ __ ] away from me like i'm literally not
interested in anything you have to say
so without being rude i just was kind of
like you know like i'm really not trying
to talk to you because i don't want him
to get the wrong idea
but what he did to get my attention like
he had seen me you know he kind of left
me alone which was cool and clearly you
know he's going to see me multiple times
at the gym but one time i was working
out
and he actually noticed i didn't have a
water bottle and um he was like
i'd already been going to the gym we've
been going to the gym for a while now he
came by he's like hey um i know you
didn't bring a water bottle today that's
sweet
gave me the water bottle and mind you i
wasn't interested in him but that was a
very good way of being like i noticed
i'm noticing
i'm fl that that is a flirt to kind of
check the temperature i think it also
depends on his delivery too and it was
honestly it was like oh hey i like i
brought you an extra water i was like
what's this for he goes oh i noticed you
didn't have a water today have a good
workout yeah and then kept it pushing
and i just was like that was so like
we're cool i'm and i don't want i didn't
want anything more from him but because
of how i reacted after he understood
like okay i tried i did something nice i
thought that was super sweet and that's
such a great approach if i was
interested i would have bit after that
that would have been the thing that made
me go okay because it shows his
personality shows that he was paying
attention shows that he also knows how
to walk away and kind of like leave a
little like i i respect you i'ma let you
know i'm interested in you yeah you know
i wasn't interested in him but that to
me is like
one of the best ways to attempt
and respectfully try
yeah and it was never awkward like he's
inviting me out or whatever but i you
know not down but it was it's never
awkward because he's probably really
securing himself and was like hey it's
it's cool i still think that's nice how
did casey flirt with you first time like
first like during the beginning stage
was there anything that he did or you're
like oh well the very very first like
extension
of uh
interaction it was through facebook he
sent me a message saying that i have a
beautiful smile and that he wanted to
work with me because back then he was
like working with a lot of music videos
and doing commercials and stuff and he
was like i would love to use you guys
thank you oh
yeah
like i remember
and it was crazy because at the time
like i was with someone and so was he
actually so i'm like what the [ __ ] you
flirting but but like he was like i
don't there was like this instant like
spark that i couldn't really explain
um but the first like in person
interaction
he was like we ended up talking about
korean barbecue and how i've never had
it and so he was just like oh my god we
gotta go like making plants making plans
it's not like
oh so um you know
whatever what do you let's hang out just
whenever no i want you to make plans
right like hey next week i'm in town
let's go do this let's do that if you're
free so he set up really direct but you
got to remember we were early 20s so it
wasn't that like secure firm kind of
like direct kind of thing but it was
like hey let's yeah i want to spend time
with you yeah yeah but the way that it
was executed though it was because it
was like oh let's just
they're press-on
um he was like oh let's set up a group
thing let's all go have a barbecue
together but then when the day came it
was like oh yeah so-and-so couldn't make
it
make it it's just us and i'm like
we never invited them i never invited
them but i like that that's the future
plan thing it's the i'm thinking about
spending time with you right the
flirting is never just like i want
successful flirting has like what's the
motive behind it and when you're trying
to like flirt with someone because you
like them as a person not just because
you want to
sleep with them like it comes off
different that's why there's like the
seductive trying to seduce and take them
to the bedroom versus the like i really
like
what a lot of people would think of you
know if it doesn't work out to be like
you guess let me but you know it's like
you give me all the relationship and the
love mommy and all that but
yeah if you want to flirt with somebody
and you want them to know like i'm
thinking long term or i'm thinking
past just getting you in my bed it's the
future plans it's the like oh yeah i
thought of you it's the small gestures
yeah and it's the checking in also the
checking in it's the being silly it's
like oh i can really be myself around
you yeah that can get confusing if a
girl tells you that though that gets
really confusing like that could be the
friendship thing that could be the
scenario that uh that person wrote like
we went on nine dates and then i'm like
she told me she felt comfortable but i
don't know how to take it to the next
step sometimes it's better to be more
cautious but
yeah the future oh my god if you are
talking to me and i am talking to you
and you are making future plans with me
i am you doing all the right things yeah
i love like like oh god oh no i was just
gonna say and that was the one that gave
him my number so i'm like hey i was
flirting back yeah you didn't realize
there you go yeah and now you got a baby
yeah
um i love when men
like i s like the planning stuff i love
when men are like i just made
reservations this place you know this is
the dress code just whatever like that i
love that so much i appreciate that more
than
um so like you know what do you feel
like yeah yeah you know i like the
assertiveness i think one of my most
favorite flirting stories ever is my dad
and my stepmom
might okay so my my family owns a nail
salon my dad does nails batman does a
full set in 20 minutes when my mom came
in he did that full set in an hour and a
half
to talk to her like to the point where
his other employees were like what's
going on here this doesn't take you that
long you know it's the cutest thing in
the world
and that's when he asked her out and
then
i love when men remember small things
about you you know like i think it's the
sweetest thing it means they're
listening they want to do something to
show you that they're listening she had
mentioned that her
her brothers love muscle cars and like
oh yeah and this weekend you know we
have a family gathering like chuck e
cheese whatever for the nephew's
birthday
my dad pulled up with his muscle car
like champion drag racing car
and
when
my stepmom's aunt comes
over to her like
some man just handed me a bouquet of
roses to give to you what and she's like
what who would he look like this is in
springfield missouri like like 10 15
years ago when there was probably like
one asian in the whole country in the
whole state and that was my dad and then
she goes what do you look like and his
her aunt goes he's asian she goes oh
okay and then he texts her like you know
until your family come outside he had
his car parked out there revving his
engine yeah the brothers come over like
oh [ __ ] i love his car she's like nice
real sweet yeah real slick yeah i love
when it gets all creative and cute like
yeah and and i can totally see why
everybody's confused about flirting
because it really changes depending on
the person and the intention behind it i
don't know how many times i can say like
the intention behind the action is
really what's going to determine like
how it goes moving forward like
are you you know how can i tell if a
girl's flirting with me when i'm in the
club first off anytime there's alcohol
involved it can get real confusing oh
yeah anytime there's alcohol or
something that can like lower your
defenses it's always going to be cute
like confusing that's why sometimes
people are like i didn't know
she wasn't flirting with me or oh i
didn't realize she just flirts with
everybody and she's so she get free
drinks like me
yeah or it's the like if someone wants
to give a situation then i'd be like
okay this is how you react if you're in
the courting phase like you know like
hey can i take you out
and then you're like okay clearly you're
interested flirting
i just feel like flirting leads to the
interested phase
like how do i get you to the next
the next level of wherever we want to go
with this so sometimes it's the it's the
subtle hair flip it's the giggling it's
me
it's the trying to be silly it's the
trying to spend time together trying to
spend time
yeah it's that like that if i you know
if i'm grooming you yeah that's how you
know i like you yeah oh wait not
grooming like creepy like like
physically like trying something yeah
yeah i'll do that to people and i'm not
trying to flirt oh but that can but if
it all goes into like the personal
bubbles
i think the the the execution because
yeah you're like lingering kind of thing
yeah you're just like oh you got some
[ __ ] right
yeah or you like see in the movies when
you're like oh let me brush your hair
off your face and then all of a sudden
they realize that
no it's it was that it was the gesture
but it was also the eye contact it was
the i'm showing you i'm caring yeah let
me fix this for you
and now i'm looking you know there's
these steps and these signs that lead
towards like i'm showing you for sure
yeah because if i'm like hey what the
[ __ ] you've got
to be like
i'm not flirting with you i'm more like
a no
like my brother
but if i was to be like oh hey you had
you had something on your pants yeah
yeah i'd be like oh she's she must have
said me
but it was like
you had something on your [ __ ] pants
i'm acknowledging you i touched you but
it's also the delivery it's also like a
voice what you're saying yes i think so
i think when i say that i awkward for it
it's more like that
i don't know i'm i'm touching you right
yeah honestly i think you know like
maybe it's like you're kind of
underselling yourself too maybe you do
not flirt but you just feel like it's
awkward i'm going to tell you she knows
how to flirt i'll tell you i'm not going
to tell you how i know but she knows how
to flirt i just ingested her fluids
earlier
okay give
right
me
contacts
nikki ingested tiffany's
that's the context oh sorry sorry from
her titties yeah wait hold on and i used
my mouth yeah yeah yeah it was delicious
no we just drink it
so exactly yeah
you do know how to flirt oh you do you
know how to flirt and
your approach your approach is sweet
you're sweet yes as someone like i
picked up i can pick up when you're when
you were flirting because it's like
there is uh your demeanor you do get shy
yeah cause i remember like first time
when i would come on you're like i'm
nervous and i'm like yeah and somebody
makes you nervous in like a sweet way
i'm like okay you like me gina is we
know we're flirting with each other and
um
i don't know
i throw my whole [ __ ] at her yeah
but also yeah she does yeah
like when gina and i flirt like we both
clearly know we're flirting with each
other but i'm like oh i know how to take
this at the next level if i wanted to
because i paid enough attention and tiff
i'd be like i don't want to do that to
you yeah i don't i don't wanna i don't
wanna play with your emotions
but you do know how to flirt so yeah
you're underselling yourself yeah thank
you so much yes you're cute you know how
to thanks everything that just happened
right now is how you responded to
somebody flirting with you and you see
see that all of that you see her whole
body language yeah yeah
this is a really informative video and i
hope you guys learned a lot and if we
missed any flirting cues that maybe you
do or you've received and you're like oh
this is another way people flirt let us
know in the comments yeah also please
make sure to check out our sponsors
that's how you show support for the show
and make sure to check out nikki blades
with all of her fantastic stuff what's
the radio station 997 now in the bay
area you can also go online and with big
bay mornings we have superb sportswear
with my sneakers on my clothing also all
things nikki blades bites with blades
nikki street eats yeah follow me on
everything and then oh no chaser sorry
sorry guys i forgot oh yeah tease it
also i'm on the no chaser podcast
with tim and rick please don't forget
that yeah we got a lot of things you're
doing sorry guys let me laugh [ __ ] we've
been doing this for three years
y'all already know at this point
everybody's like where's tim not sure
it's my turn
yeah check out gina on her twitch stream
and on g4 and then check out my tiffin
case channel where you'll see
casey flirting with
she's cute
see you guys next time
[Music]
you